you're seeing this now in some of what's
coming to light from covid the new CDC
director a woman named Mandy Cohen just
recounted how she as then North Carolina
Health director
came up with her covid mandates
I would call probably the person I
called most was the Secretary of Health
and Human Services in Massachusetts she
worked for Republican Governor just to
um but you know when she was like are
you are you going to let them have
professional
um uh football and I was like nope and
she's like okay neither are we neither
are we uh
um so uh you know it was like
conversations like that so or or I'd be
like so when are you gonna think about
lightening up a mess or like you're like
next Monday I'm like okay next Monday
just a couple girls Gavin you know hey
hey Shirley
are you gonna let are you gonna let your
guys go to their grandparents funerals
nah okay yeah I didn't know I was sort
of like just flip a coin I don't know
so
how was your day what do you think
this was just a couple of girls gabbing
this was not the inerrant infallible
voice of science with a capital s
this is politics not science hey you
think we can get away with this nah okay
we won't push that hard
what about this yeah we could probably
do that we probably can't shut down
these BLM riots right anyway it's really
important they go out there and they
Riot but we can stop the conservatives
from going to church can't yeah okay
good okay we'll do that that's good
hey
do you think we should uh tell the the
orgy people to stop doing the orgy stuff
because monkey pox is spreading a lot
no we like Pride yay Pride okay that's
fine forget about that one but we'll
tell the conservatives that they have to
shut down their businesses right yeah
okay good
good politics not science of course
which frankly
is how it should be
Dr fauci was always wrong and he was
always a liar maybe he was just totally
ignorant of of what politics and science
are I don't I don't put just total
benighted ignorance past the man
but public policy is always about
politics and trade-offs and what kind of
society we want to live in when the libs
say look it's more important to us that
we have the big rainbow parades than
that we stop the spread of monkey pox
that's a legitimate political position
to hold it's not a very smart one but
it's a legitimate political position to
hold you're saying we want a cultural
and sexual Revolution more than we want
to stop people from Catching this STD
when when the libs came out and they
said we support the BLM riots
even though it'll spread covid we
support the BLM rights it's more
important that the libs go out and burn
down the the buildings and loot the Nike
stores then that we stop the spread of
this flu-like disease that's a
legitimate political position to hold
the promise we were told that it wasn't
political we were told that we're not
allowed to have political views
ourselves and we're not we're not
allowed to support them
this is this is an admission of what the
conservatives knew the whole time and
it's a return to something that's more
normal and more basic which is
self-government right now text Knowles
to 98 98 98 president Trump recently
issued a warning from his Mar-A-Lago
home quote our currency is crashing and
will soon no longer be the world's
standard which will be our greatest
defeat frankly in 200 years there are
three reasons the central banks are
dumping the U.S dollar inflation deficit
spending and our insurmountable national
debt the fact is there is one asset that
is what stood famine Wars and political
economic upheaval dating back to ancient
times gold you can own gold in a tax
sheltered retirement account with the
help of Birch gold that is right Birch
gold will help you convert an existing
Ira or 401K maybe from a previous
employer into an IRA in Gold best part
is you don't pay a penny out of pocket
text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 for your
free info kit they will hold your hand
through the entire process think about
this when currency sees fail gold is a
safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold today Birch gold has an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers text
Knowles to 98 98 98 to get your free
info kit on gold that is Knowles kwles
to 98 98 98 right now go to
preparewithknolls.com I love that URL in
a world filled with uncertainties it is
crucial to be ready for whatever comes
your way whether it's a natural disaster
a sudden emergency or unforeseen
circumstances having a reliable food
storage system can provide you with
peace of mind and the assurance that you
and your loved ones will be well taken
care of right now my Patriot Supply is
knocking 200 off their popular
three-month emergency food kit to help
you start growing your supply go to
preparewithnowles.com grab this special
price before it ends your three-month
emergency food kit provides over 2 000
calories each day for optimal strength
and energy in stressful situations you
can enjoy a wide variety of my Patriot
Supply food from buttermilk pancakes and
chicken alfredo to rice pudding their
meals have you covered for every part of
your day best part is each meal is
delicious don't wait for disaster to
strike before taking action invest in
your safety and well-being by securing
your food storage today go to
preparewithknolls.com save 200 on each
kit your family needs prepare with
knowles.com right now that is prepare
with knowles.com now science
for all of its flaws you know I'm very
skeptical of science
skeptical not just of scientism and the
lab coat people and those who have
perverted science I'm skeptical of
basically the entire scientific project
I'm skeptical of the way of thinking
that has characterized the Western mind
since the Scientific Revolution I'm
skeptical of arguments about what a
woman is let's say that that nearly boil
down to 2x chromosomes in a uterus I
just think that's reductive and soul
denying and and ignores the metaphysical
basis of reality so I'm kind of down on
science but there's some good stuff that
comes out of scientific and
technological advancement
one piece of evidence for this would be
the baby boxes
and specifically a baby box in Knoxville
have you heard of baby boxes baby boxes
are exactly what they sound like
it's a safe haven box
where
mothers
who choose not to kill their children
through abortion who choose to give
birth to the children but don't know
what to do with them once the children
are born
they can just drop the baby off usually
at a firehouse or or police station
put the baby in a box and baby will then
be put up for adoption
we'll go into a sort of orphanage foster
care system but then hopefully be put up
for adoption
um this used to happen people would
leave
babies at the fire department
but the babies could die of exposure I
mean this has happened before abandoned
babies will die of exposure very quickly
these are these are very vulnerable
creatures so the baby box was invented
to be climate controlled to be very safe
to give First Responders an opportunity
to come and help the babies out this has
now been used in Knoxville
Tennessee's first Safe Haven baby box
was used for the first time this was
about a couple of weeks ago
according to the Knoxville fire
department and the baby was
approximately 30 minutes old
firefighters called an ambulance they
took the baby to the hospital the baby
is doing very well great stuff reminder
that conservatives cannot totally turn
our back on technology I don't really
like modern technology at all I'm not a
big fan of having screens everywhere any
I basically never texted anybody back I
I'm not but
this is a great example of saying as
technology advances let's turn it to our
own good well the libs are turning
technology toward creating babies and
Laboratories and in insisting upon these
designer baby Eugenics campaigns that
are ghoulish and anti-human well well
the libs are turning the technology
toward killing babies the conservatives
are going to turn that technology toward
saving babies who are in danger and that
is great news boy what a great clip that
was make sure you subscribe ring that
Bell to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time